Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
[Azione chiama, genera,
crea, ispira azione]
[Il conto alla rovescia
non lascia scampo]
[Possiamo fermare
il cambiamento climatico]
Non sono mai stata
un'ambientalista, un'ecologista
né tantomeno un'attivista:
delle conseguenze dei miei consumi
non me ne è mai fregato
assolutamente niente.
Da brava figlia degli anni '80,
sono sempre stata
la consumatrice perfetta.
Davanti a un banco dell'alimentare,
due erano le domande che mi facevo:
Quanto costa? E farà ingrassare?
Quando percorrevo
le corsie del supermercato
dei prodotti per l'igiene personale,
annusavo tutti i flaconi:
mora, lavanda, lampone - cosa scegliere?
E che dire dei prodotti per pulire casa?
Al massimo, mi potevo chiedere
se era meglio spray o gel.
Poi, un giorno, è cambiato tutto.
Avevo 31 anni e mi sentivo arrivata:
il lavoro dei sogni;
i colleghi eccezionali; i buoni pasto;
ferie e straordinari pagati.
Era tutto perfetto.
Talmente perfetto che decido di firmare
un mutuo trentennale per acquistare casa.
Tanto, cosa sarebbe potuto andar male?
Troppi contratti consecutivi
a tempo determinato:
ci lasciano a casa in blocco.
Lì per lì, non mi scoraggio.
E penso: con il mio curriculum,
le mie conoscenze, le mie esperienze,
vuoi che non trovo niente?
Colleziono una serie di contratti
davvero poco dignitosi,
e poi eccola: la disoccupazione.
Perdere il lavoro non è solo
una questione economica.
Quando per tutta la vita
ti identifichi con quello che fai,
nel momento in cui non fai più nulla
a venirti a mancare
non è solo lo stipendio,
è la tua stessa identità.
Se non ero quello che facevo,
i vestiti che compravo,
la gente che frequentavo,
chi ero?
Come sempre succede, le crisi
ci mettono di fronte a un bivio:
soccombere, o reagire.
Io, in quel momento, ho deciso di reagire.
E l'ho fatto ripartendo
da me, dalle mie azioni.
Per esempio, mi sono detta:
viste le ridottissime possibilità
economiche che avevo,
perché dovevo continuare
a pagare per avvelenarmi?
È successo da un giorno all'altro:
dopo 15 anni di onoratisima carriera
da fumatrice incallita,
al ritmo di un pacchetto
di sigarette al giorno,
per quasi 20.000 euro spesi
nell'arco di una vita,
ho smesso di fumare.
È stato incredibile.
Per la prima volta, ho percepito
il potere enorme che avevo tra le mani:
il potere di scegliere.
Ho utilizzato tutto
il mio tempo per informarmi.
Dopo il fumo, è stata la volta del cibo.
E dopo il cibo, è stata la volta
dei prodotti per pulire casa,
quelli per l'igiene personale.
Più mi informavo,
più aumentava in me
una nuova consapevolezza.
Avevo imparato a leggere le etichette,
e avevo scoperto che quando,
sulla mia confezione di shampoo,
c'era scritto in piccolo
piccolo piccolo piccolo,
la parola "petrolati"
significava che davvero
mi stavo lavando i capelli
con dei derivati del petrolio.
Ho scoperto che quando,
nelle confezioni di creme,
c'è scritto la parola "siliconi"
stiamo parlando di quelle stesse sostanze
che in genere si utilizzano
per sigillare la doccia.
La mia pelle era asfissiata.
Leggendo i libri
del professor Franco Berrino,
ho scoperto che tre tumori
su dieci nascono a tavola,
e che semplicemente cambiando
le nostre abitudini alimentari
potremmo fare tantissimo
per la nostra salute.
Ho scoperto che per fare un chilo di carne
servono 15.000 litri d'acqua,
e che sono troppi:
non ce li possiamo più permettere.
Ho scoperto che l'aria
che respiravo dentro casa mia
era peggio di quella
che respiravo con il motorino
sul Grande Raccordo Anulare
nell'ora di punta,
e che l'inquinamento indoor
fa molti più morti,
e più malati, di quello esterno.
Ma soprattutto, mi sono imbattuta
in un concetto bellissimo:
quello di impronta ecologica.
Non ne sapevo assolutamente nulla.
L'impronta ecologica
è una formula matematica
che ci dice l'insieme di risorse
che vengono utilizzate per produrre,
e smaltire, un determinato bene.
Questo ci fa capire
che il prezzo di ciò che compriamo
non corrisponde mai al loro valore.
Comprare era diventato difficilissimo.
Entravo nei supermercati
e non vedevo più gli sconti,
le promesse del marketing, i colori:
vedevo l'impatto sociale, ambientale
e sanitario delle mie scelte.
Vedevo le facce dei lavoratori
che le avevano prodotte:
gente sfruttata, maltrattata, sottopagata.
Nel momento in cui io ero lì
a battere i piedi
per rivendicare i miei diritti
di lavoratrice,
la mia dignità professionale,
puntualmente spendevo i miei pochi soldi
per finanziare aziende
che trattavano i lavoratori
come io per prima
non volevo essere trattata.
Non volevo più essere complice.
Era il 2 gennaio del 2015
quando, uscendo da un supermercato,
mi sono promessa di non rientrarci più.
È iniziato così il mio anno fuori
dalla Grande Distribuzione Organizzata.
Un anno incredibile:
ma all'inizio, parecchio duro.
Grattavo, letteralmente,
il fondo degli armadietti.
Per fortuna avevo un GAS,
che mi ha salvato la vita.
Un GAS, un Gruppo d'Acquisto Solidale,
è un insieme di persone che si riuniscono
per acquistare direttamente
dai produttori.
Con il GAS si può trovare di tutto,
e tutto quello che si trova
ha alle spalle una storia meravigliosa.
Per esempio, le nostre arance
arrivano da una piccola azienda
agricola della Calabria:
terra bellissima ma molto ostica,
soprattutto per i raccoglitori di arance.
Grazie ai GAS del Lazio,
questa azienda ha potuto mettere
in regola i propri dipendenti,
garantirsi un guadagno dignitoso
e convertirsi in biologico.
Il nostro caffè arriva direttamente
da una cooperativa agricola del Chapas,
che ogni anno prefinanziamo.
Cosa significa che la prefinanziamo?
Significa che noi paghiamo
il caffè a febbraio
e lo riceviamo ad agosto.
Un tempo un po' lunghino,
starete pensando.
Sì.
Ma forse, non sapete che in quei mesi
succede qualcosa di magico.
Succede che grazie
al nostro prefinanziamento,
questa cooperativa agricola
evita di indebitarsi.
Di richiedere prestiti,
a tassi da usuraio, alle banche;
o di rivolgersi direttamente
a degli strozzini.
Noi, in cambio, beviamo un ottimo caffè,
prodotto senza veleni
e soprattutto senza sfruttamento:
di bambini in primis,
una delle piaghe più tragiche
della filiera del caffè.
Oltre al GAS, ho scoperto
che il mio quartiere era popolato
da tantissimi negozietti, botteghe,
e luoghi carinissimi in cui fare la spesa.
Alcuni vendevano sfuso: io andavo lì,
con i miei barattoli, le mie buste,
e compravo senza imballaggi,
senza fare rifiuti.
Poi ho conosciuto i mercati contadini,
dove ci sono davvero i contadini,
cioè quelle persone
che dedicano la loro vita
a prendersi cura della terra,
dei semi, del cibo.
Sono praticamente degli eroi!
Grazie a loro, la mia spesa è cambiata.
Compro meno e compro meglio;
compro sfuso; compro locale;
e soprattutto, compro di stagione.
Nel mio frigo non ci sono più
le zucchine a dicembre,
e i pomodori tutto l'anno.
Perché alla varietà dei supermercati,
oggi preferisco la biodiversità dei campi.
E soprattutto, vado alla ricerca
delle materie prime, più sane, genuine.
Perché in quest'anno senza supermercato
ho scoperto una cosa bellissima:
il piacere di saper fare.
Era l'inizio di quest'avventura quando,
non sapendo dove sbattere la testa,
leggo che a Roma,
alla "Città dell'Altra Economia",
presentavano un libro:
"Fatto in casa", di Lucia Cuffaro.
Mi fiondo, piena di pregiudizi:
pensavo di trovarmi nel circolo
della casalinga disperata.
E invece no.
E invece lì scopro che l'autoproduzione
può essere davvero rivoluzionaria.
Che autoproduzione
è sinonimo di autosufficienza;
e che quando sei autosufficiente,
puoi scegliere con consapevolezza,
puoi essere indipendente.
Questo significa essere liberi.
Alla fine dell'incontro mi sono detta:
se solo le persone mettessero in pratica
una piccola parte di quello
che hanno detto qua oggi,
questo mondo cambierebbe
da un giorno all'altro, da così a così.
E noi tutti potremmo essere più felici.
Ora, con poche sostanze riesco
a autoprodurmi tantissime cose.
Per esempio il mio deodorante,
fatto con amido di mais,
bicarbonato e Tea Tree Oil:
funziona.
Oppure il dentifricio:
argilla bianca, bicarbonato,
qualche olio essenziale
di menta e tea tree oil.
Pochi secondi, pochissimi centesimi,
e il gioco è fatto.
Al posto di brillantante,
ammorbidamente e anticalcare
uso l'acido citrico.
Il disinfettante,
lo smacchiatore e lo sbiancante
li ho sostituiti
con il percarbonato di sodio:
una sorta di candeggina naturale
che non intossica né me né l'ambiente.
I vantaggi sono tantissimi:
risparmio, certo;
ci guadagno tantissimo in salute;
l'ambiente mi ringrazia;
e soprattutto, guadagno tempo.
Il tempo è prezioso.
Prima, il mio sabato pomeriggio
era dedicato alla spesa.
Non so se avete presente
cos'è un centro commerciale a Roma,
il sabato pomeriggio.
Tra la ricerca del parcheggio,
la rincorsa del carrello,
la coda estenuante alla cassa,
stiamo parlando di un girone dell'inferno.
Ora il mio sabato pomeriggio è libero,
e fare la spesa è un piacere.
Che sia GAS, che siano mercati,
che sia la bottega sotto casa,
è sempre l'occasione
per fare quattro chiacchiere,
un sorriso, un assaggio.
Forse la cosa più bella
di tutta questa storia
è proprio questa:
l'insieme delle relazioni
che si sono create
attorno alla mia nuova spesa.
Storie bellissime,
che insieme ad alcuni amici
abbiamo provato a raccontare,
creando la mappa
dell'Italia senza supermercato.
All'inizio poche realtà,
a cui si sono aggiunte
centinaia e centinaia di altre storie:
allevatori, agricoltori,
artigiani, piccoli commercianti.
Persone eccezionali,
che stanno dedicando la loro vita
a creare un'economia virtuosa, reale.
Si prendono cura dei territori:
li custodiscono, contrastano l'abbandono;
e soprattutto, producono
un cibo sano per tutti.
Che sia un diritto, e non solo una merce.
Da queste persone
ho imparato una gran cosa:
che non c'è niente di meglio
che amare il proprio lavoro.
Alla fine di quest'anno
senza supermercato,
ho firmato una lettera di dimissioni.
Avevo trovato il buon lavoro,
a tempo indeterminato.
Ero ancora una volta arrivata:
eppure, grazie a questa gente
ho preso il coraggio a due mani
e mi sono licenziata.
Poi ho lasciato la casa, il mutuo;
ho fatto valigie; ho venduto cose.
Perché in quest'anno senza supermercato,
ho capito che meno è meglio.
E che vivere "senza"
non significa rinunciare
assolutamente a nulla, anzi.
Riscoprire la bellezza delle essenziale,
e il piacere di saper fare,
la gioia di prendersi cura
di se stessi e degli altri.
Anche attraverso le proprie azioni,
anche attraverso i propri acquisti.
Alla fine di quest'anno
senza supermercato,
ho capito che fare la spesa,
decidere a chi diamo i nostri soldi,
è un atto profondamente politico,
sovversivo, rivoluzionario.
Ho capito che ogni volta
che metto mano al portafoglio,
e pago qualcuno,
gli sto dando una pacca sulla spalla
e gli sto dicendo: "Bravo, mi piace
quello che fai, continua così".
Ho capito che tirar fuori un euro,
e comprare qualcosa,
non significa semplicemente
comprare qualcosa.
Significa decidere in che mondo,
e in che modo, voglio vivere.
E forse è arrivato il momento
di esserne tutti un po' più consapevoli.
Grazie.
(Applausi)